- I think I got drunk
on Vodka for my 21st...
- But you couldn't remember.
- but I couldn't remember.
(mariachi music)
- I am reliving my
freshman year of college.
- I'm not reliving my
- I'm going to judge based on
burning sensation, not taste.
- Here goes.
- Bring out the vodka!
(mariachi music)
- First glance, there is no difference.
The left one has no
smell and the right one
totally has a rubbing alcohol smell.
- No, this one I wanna clean
algae off a fish tank with.
(smacking)
- That's pretty smooth vodka.
- That one tastes like
maybe it was sitting
in a plastic bottle.
- No, maybe this will be the better one
(coughs).
- Much better.
- More expensive.
Oh God, wait! Nope, much better.
- That one was better.
- Really?
- That one was smoother.
- Yeah, expensive, cheap. (buzzer buzzes)
- Yeah. (buzzer buzzes)
- Expensive, cheap. (buzzer buzzes)
- OK, well then, expensive,
cheap. (bell dings)
- I'm gonna say this is
the more expensive one.
- I say this is the more expensive one.
- This was less, this was cheap?
- What?
- Are you kidding?
- I'm a Vodka expert.
- After two sips! (laughs)
(mariachi music)
- That one was kinda sweet.
- Yeah.
- It just tasted really
sharp to me and it was...
- But it was sharp in like a good way.
- Ooh, I don't know.
- Ouch!
- (laughs) Exactly!
- Oh, God.
- That one wasn't bad!
- No.
- That one was good.
- No it wasn't!
- That was so smooth.
- This is the more expensive one.
- Really? All right, I'm
gonna agree with you.
- I'm gonna go with you,
cheap and expensive.
- I'm gonna say that's expensive.
That one's cheap. (bell dings)
- I'm gonna disagree. (buzzer buzzes)
I'm not liking the expensive ones at all!
- That's great! That's great news!
- That is great news!
- Why do I feel bad?
(mariachi music)
- Mm
- (sighs) That was nice.
- What is...?
- Oh no, no.
- (coughs)
- Yeah, that's like water.
- That is like water.
- You don't sound like
it sounds like water.
- It's like deep burning water.
(laughs)
- It's such a strong gasoline taste.
- Expensive (bell dings)
- Very cheap.
- I'll agree with you and say this was
the more expensive one.
- This was the more expensive one?
- All right, I'm saying
this was most expensive.
- We're gonna go together. (bell dings)
- Yes!
I got one!
I'm a cheap date!
I'm OK, I'm gonna embrace
it and I'm proud of it,
and (bleep) you guys.
(laughs)